aberkane idriss aberkane pardon il est
enseignant conférencier essayiste il
dévisse à berkane bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl alors l'action de gamestop elle a
chuté en bourse un depuis quelques jours
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
ça veut dire qu'on n'a plus le droit de
l'acheter tout simplement
il a été interdit de lâcheté par
plusieurs opérateurs boursiers
de sorte que si vous ne pouvez plus
acheter un titre évidemment il
s'effondre alors les les boursicoteurs
amateurs du réseau social américain
heureux dit on l'a vu ne se sont pas
arrêtés là après avoir fait remonter le
cours de gamestop depuis quelques jours
il s'attaque au cours de l'argent
pourquoi expliqué nous c'est de la même
façon si vous voulez c'est une évolution
du mouvement occupy wall street dont
vous aviez beaucoup parlé je me souviens
sur rt nous avions un mouvement où les
gens voulaient occuper wall street mais
de l'extérieur et maintenant on commence
à avoir une sorte de occupy wall street
de l'intérieur c'est à dire que les gens
ne manifestent plus avec leurs jambes
mais ils manifestent avec leur
portefeuille et ça fait beaucoup plus
mal alors est ce que cela montre une
certaine faiblesse de wall street
est ce que le système boursier et
capitaliste est remis en question
qu'est ce que révèle au fond cette
affaire elle révèle réellement que les
manifestations sont en train de ce
financier risée et ça c'est un moment
historique
j'insiste si on devait tout résumer ce
dossier en une seule phrase c'est la
première manifestation financière de
l'histoire
c'est la première fois que des
manifestants qui ont des revendications
d'ordre politique et sociale comme
n'importe quel manifestants dans le
monde se mette à manifester non plus
avec leurs jambes mais avec leur
portefeuille et l'effet de levier est
énorme et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
obtenus en même pas une semaine
finalement une sorte de bousculades
complète de wall street avec même
maintenant évidemment annulant
régulateur considérable il n'avait
jamais obtenu avant alors est dédié
on a class américaine on les a entendus
demande d'une enquête demande de
réformer wall street il faut réformer
wall street aujourd'hui selon vous oui
il faut mais là ce sont vraiment des
larmes de crocodile qui sont versés dans
cette aventure ce qu'il faut savoir sur
gamestop c'est donc si on reprend toute
la chronologie
nous avions des fonds vautours qui
spéculaient sur la mort de gamestop
donc il est spéculé à la baisse il
pariait sur le fait que gamestop allait
mourir
et bien évidemment que tous les employés
allaient finir au chômage dans la pire
crise sanitaire de notre époque on peut
pas vraiment appeler ces gens les
gentils si vous voulez or ces fonds
vautours qui spéculaient sur la bête de
gamestop se sont pris par donner moins
une raclée quand des petits porteurs ont
acheté l'action
comment ça s'est passé très concrètement
très concrètement vous misez à la baisse
dont vous faites un pari que l'action va
baisser si elle monte est bien là aussi
je vais utiliser un terme très technique
vous l'avez dans l'os
et quand je dis vous l'avez dans l'os et
plusieurs milliards de dollars que vous
avez dans l'os or c'est ce qui s'est
passé ces fonds spéculatifs avaient fait
un énorme pari que gamestop allaient
baisser
gamestop à monter parce que des petits
porteurs ont acheté l'action en mars en
s'organisant sur les réseaux sociaux et
à partir de là eh bien ces fonds
spéculatifs ont été ruinés donc ces
fonds quand tu ne gagnes
ils veulent surtout pas de régulation et
10 au monde entier qu'il faut laisser le
marché libre et non faussée et qu'il ne
faut pas donc de régulation mais quand
ils perdent ce sont les premiers à aller
pleurer auprès des régulateurs en disant
que c'est pas juste que les petits
porteurs fasse les mêmes manipulations
que et dont évidemment comme ils ont des
contacts aux politiques ils obtiennent
une régulation très rapidement donc on
voit bien que ce sont des gens qui
trichent réellement c'est à dire que
quand ils gagnent ils ne veulent pas de
régulation quand ils perdent ils
supplient les régulateurs d'intervenir
on connaît le fameux proverbe c'est la
privatisation des bénéfices et la
socialisation des pertes
et est ce que ce genre d'événement
pourrait se produire en france
alors oui potentiellement ce genre
d'événement pourrait se produire en
france si des français s'organisait sur
un réseau social pour acheter une action
en masse pour lutter contre une
spéculation
alors il y a moins de fonds vautours en
france cela dit il y à des fonds
vautours un peu partout en europe qui
pourrait spéculer à la baisse sur une
sommes une société en france on a eu des
ventes de sociétés particulièrement
touchés politiquement je pense à la à la
vente d'alstom je pense en ce moment à
la privatisation au démantèlement d'edf
le monde diplomatique a fait un sujet là
dessus et bien plutôt que d'aller
manifester effectivement si des petits
porteurs s'organisait et se mettaient à
acheter massivement le cours d'une
action
une action pour soutenir son cours nous
pourrions avoir exactement le même
phénomène
merci beaucoup hybris aberkane pour cet
éclairage je le rappelle vous êtes
enseignant conférencier et essayer